[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
fat man Beyond it's a home episode it's
a black man Beyond episode it's a solo
episode because Kevin is still in
production on June 7th reboot and I had
to go see Captain Marvel by myself and
we'll also have to review it by myself
so here I am reviewing it by myself
um oh yeah I go to every Marvel movie
every comic book movie with a sense
hopefully of some cautious optimism
right like I'm hoping they're all good
pardon my shaky hands I always thought
they're good I always hope that they
they add something to the cannon I
always hope they they they proved
themselves worth the time and the effort
and the love that we as fans devote to
this entire crazy enterprise and and I'm
sort of of two minds of Captain Marvel
after having seen it twice I went I went
on opening day and then I went again
today to go see it because when I first
got out of the theater I was I was
little crestfallen
because I wasn't there's there's some
stuff that I that I really do like in
this movie quite a bit I think brie
Larson is fantastic I think that Jude
Law is a ton of fun like I I'm trying to
remember the time that I saw a lot of
thing and didn't think it was a ton of
fun because he is at the stage in career
where scenery is meant to be chewed and
he does he with a wink and a smile and
that guy has always been able to convey
some semblance of malice or at least
some semblance of what you what you see
is not what you get and there's more
beneath that particular surface so I
thought he was fantastic but my my
issues with the movie were such were
they were emotional ultimately they were
that I found it hard to emotionally
engage with fears until she becomes
Caliban
and like that I get that's part of the
structure of the movie is that it's it's
somewhat a mystery where your main
character is uncovering her own identity
but as such because because hal danvers
because veers doesn't actively engage
with who she is and what she wants the
movie as such doesn't have a main
character a protagonist who engages with
who she is and what she wants so for
almost half the movie veers is I mean we
first meet her on anjala that we first
meet her being told to to control her
emotions and not let the emotions get
the better of her and to be the best
version of herself and to do that means
to sublimate everything that makes her
special and I thought did that that
thread was was set up kind of strong and
then not pulled through enough of the
movie if you know what I mean like I
there's parts of that movie that
absolutely feel like they're about a
woman who's been told not to be who she
is because who she is is a liability as
a detriment is you know the the the the
outward display of emotion is israa
bohtan for her and so the idea that she
went over the course of the movie
uncover and unlock her true potential
visa vie her emotions is really kind of
strong and but and the movie flirts with
him movie flirts with those scenes of
flashbacks two guys telling her you know
you can't go too fast you can't jump so
high you'll never be able to fly a jet
you'll never be able to fly in combat
the world telling her the things that
she can't do because of who she is and
then for that to kind of loop back
around in the end and and and and her
power comes from repudiating that very
idea that there needs to be controls on
who she is that there need to be
overrides to her sense of power in her
sense of place but because veers is a
separated from from jula for much of the
middle of the movie and because
she doesn't have access to and isn't
driven by a desire to uncover those
memories they don't really drive her you
know like her mission as she sees it is
to stop Scrolls from infiltrating earth
to get a Lightspeed drive to do
something and and this the scrolls
there's like five of them and they never
seem that threatening because they don't
want that ultimately so it feels a bit
like those Marvel movies where there's
the here's the shiny MacGuffin that your
hero has to get and and and either will
be or it won't be that thing but it
doesn't matter really to what happens in
the movie and bets never lying be like
they need to find a Lightspeed drive on
earth which is galaxies away from where
how long and the scrolls are from and so
somehow the scrolls and the Kree can get
to earth anyway and maybe it takes a
little bit longer but they can still get
there but a light speed drive will get
them there faster okay sure if you want
so by the time you know
Kalen danvers or veers makes it to earth
she's not engaging with earth in any
real way you know she lands on earth and
she's like a cop on a quest she's on a
cage she's gotta find this and she's
something clues and but other than a
couple of like a hallucination she's
never actually interfacing engaging and
reckoning with the fact that earth
should feel familiar to her the music
that she hears should feel familiar the
places that you go should feel familiar
when she goes to someplace that should
feel like home it should feel that way
and the movie doesn't give us that the
movie gives us fears at an emotional
remove and therefore us at an emotional
removed from her because we don't know
what's driving or we don't know what she
wants we don't know we don't know how
the things that she does are answering
questions for her that will explain who
she is and where she comes from because
she doesn't care for much of that movie
it's only when she meets Maria Rambo
it's only when her former best friend
gets to sit down and tell her this is
who you were this is what you meant this
is you were you were the strongest most
powerful person I ever knew and that was
before you've got your crazy light
powers that stuff lands like a ton of
bricks like that stuff is killer and
that stuff gives you the emotional drive
that that for me the first hour that
movie didn't quite have I mean and
guardians shows that you can do the kind
of interstellar adventure but still
brooding in what feels like I mean Peter
quill was all about running away from
from responsibility from the tether from
from the people who would care for him
and the people that he needed to care
for because in a jump of that movie we
realized that he's not ready to reckon
with the people who love that he loves
leaving him but we don't get that here
and it's it's a structural thing is
their desire they desired not to go down
that route and and for me that that it
left me a little bit cold until you get
to that moment where here's who you are
and here's what you mean and here's why
you're special because of who you used
to be before you turned into this you
know and and there's there's a moment at
the end of the movie I mean we're gonna
spoil it a bit because at this point
you've seen it we know who we are where
we're Cal Danvers learns to fly and I
feel like the movie wanted that to be a
bigger moment than it honestly was in
the movie and and there's a simple way
to get there I mean it requires a little
bit of retrofitting and engineering but
there's a sabore to get there make it so
that Carol Danvers never was able to fly
jets that the army not just wasn't
letting her fly combat missions but
wasn't even letting her get behind the
stick that she Maria were helicopter
pilots you can make it abate they could
fly Apaches they could even fly gunships
not to combat but like they could still
fly stuff with guns and they were the
best at that but
always looked over they always
supersonic flag that was one to break
the sound barrier and they never could
they were never allowed to and so you
still get to have you know if you want
you can still get to have veers flying a
helicopter out of the Pegasus base you
still get to have Maria Rambo leading
you know an awesome flight chase down
from the from Marvel's lab but that
moment when she discovers that she can't
break the speed barrier I mean the sound
barrier when she can go supersonic and
she doesn't need a plane to do it
because was within her all along I mean
then that moment the girl who could
never fly can finally fly like then it's
it's nothing but emotion it's nothing
but exultation it's nothing but triumph
whereas now it's just look at this cool
thing that I can do as opposed to look
at this dream that's finally coming true
for me and I can also use it to punch
things in the face a lot I feel like
that that would have helped close the
emotional loop for me on what her story
was but like there's the the second time
I saw it I enjoyed it more than I did
the first time because the you know
movies are all about empathy right
you're it's all about sympathy nobody
you're trying to sympathize and
empathize and personify yourself in the
main character and and it was only on
the second time that I was able to kind
of work my way in and see the the kind
of emotional pull especially where the
emotional pull pulled me harder the
second wait that sounds dirty it worked
better the second time around maybe
because I wasn't I wasn't scratching my
hands to why I didn't have it I was
looking for where they sort of hit it
and in that moment again where Maria
limbo tells her here's who you used to
be and here's why I loved you hit a lot
harder for me the second time around the
moment when you know she breaks free of
the supreme intelligence and and and and
burns off her own little inhibitor
device hit harder
the the big twist in the movie the fact
that the create that's yeah the scroll
are not infiltrators as much as they are
refugees a very conscious decision you
know and I think now the second Marvel
movie that ultimately is about a refugee
story after Thor Ragnarok that twist is
great you know that twist of you know
here's where I thought with the bad guys
who were just on the run here's who I
thought the good guys were actually the
bad guys here's who I thought trusted me
and believed in me and supported me and
encouraged me but ended up being the
people who were just holding me back and
keeping me down and and sublimating
everything that made me glorious and
wonderful i twist is great i think i
think the movie lives in the second half
more than it does the first half because
it just didn't have a kind of overriding
principle it didn't have a question it
didn't have an emotional question I
needed answered it had a lot of plot
questions it was going through the beat
so but it's only when she engages with
herself that the movie actually takes
off I think Sam Jackson was good I think
that that he's having a ton of fun I
can't quite square this theory with the
fury you see later they just seem a
little bit like two different people
this one is a lot more fun and and by
the time we first meet him you know I
mean we don't really we see him and I
know we don't meet him for real until
later he's a far more serious person and
yes I'm sure there's story to go between
now and then the awful things that
happened and senator Pierce and all that
stuff but yeah it seems like he's a he's
a slightly weirder dude here's a lighter
guy I think the the CG the CGS
enchanting is amazing the CG on Phil
Coulson um a little less so the Clark
Gregg stuff you look plastic er than I
would have liked but but like all of
that stuff is it's it's it's fun like
inner nerd stuff it's fun like checking
boxes of like okay we're connecting
these dots and these lines and you know
when is when isn't if you're going to
lose that eye
you know when I thought it was a green
ad that went off I thought it was okay I
don't know
I thought Winter Soldier had a different
origin story for how he lost his eyes
supposed to I got scratched with a cat
unless he's inventing that story as he
goes but but yeah you know it's it's if
I if I had to rank it um I don't I don't
feel like it's top tier Marvel I don't
think it reaches the heights of Winter
Soldier Civil War or Ragnarok or First
Avenger or the first Avengers yeah yeah
and I don't think it's it's bad as door
two or Iron Man 2 or the Incredible Hulk
I think it's it's kind of solidly right
in the middle it's um which which to me
is a bit of it is a bit of a shame like
it's there was a ton of potential there
and and there's still a lot of good
there but I think that at at the end of
the day is it is square in the middle
you know it's not quite as fun as
guardians it's it still it probably got
as much stakes as ant-man which I
thought it would have had more stakes
than that and some of the filmmaking
just from a little uninspired especially
in the first half you know like there
were there were action scenes that did
nothing but action you know like what
what did we really learn from the train
sequence other than an amazing cameo and
and yeah like I knew it was coming
because Kevin it was coming but it's so
it's super sweet it is super sweet and
and yeah I know that meant the world to
keV you know but that sequence doesn't
give you anything besides a clue trail
it does a really reveal character it
doesn't really you know enhance our
emotional understanding of who fears
even is at that point or what the
squirrels want in that point you know
like the the whole first thing on
whatever planet they go to to get
a spy that they don't get it's just it
feels like we we need an action scene
here not because it's gonna do anything
for us it just needs to be action here
we need to get the plot going we need to
we need to instigate what's happening I
mean I would have liked to have lived
more in you know 1989 calibers like give
us more of that stuff I want to live
more with calibers before she becomes
Vere's I just feel like we'd have all of
that stuff would have land a little bit
harder we would have dug in better we
would have been one of vested in her if
they didn't treat her backstory like it
was just backstory if it was actual
motivation for her if it was actual
here's what she's trying to get back to
here's the world in which she
desperately misses and doesn't know she
misses it and when she returns hearth
when she crashes through a blockbuster
she discovers that she is having sense
memories of things she doesn't recognize
and how profoundly weird that must be
yeah the the movie never lives in the
experience of not knowing who you are or
where you're from and being reminded
more than periodically that that what
you think is true isn't that the ground
you think is solid isn't and for me that
would that would have elevated it beyond
a perfectly perfectly entertaining
afternoon at the movies I mean I
definitely I definitely can't say that I
mean by no stretch that I hate this
movie but I didn't love it and I really
wanted to love it because there's
there's a lot to love in it it's just
not quite shined the way for me
personally I would have I would have
preferred so yeah that is my Captain
Marvel review I and you know it's it's
perfectly fine to not like a thing it's
perfectly fine to love a thing it's
perfectly fine to live in in a Mid State
between the two and it's perfect if I
have conflicted opinions about moving it
is uh it is less than perfectly fine to
refute a very movies stretch that it's
perfectly fine you know where I'm going
don't be an [ __ ] the Internet's
filled with [ __ ] don't be that
person
don't be the person who doesn't like
kept the novel because it's Captain
Marvel don't be the kind of person who
doesn't like Captain Marvel because it
stars a lady don't be that person who
goes in the internet and and bashes
people and scuttles Rotten Tomatoes and
and tries their best to sabotage what is
just a movie
when is just a movie that will provide
joy for some entertainment for others
but it it in no way deserves that we as
fans do not deserve that the culture
doesn't deserve that
so yeah let's let's be better let's hire
further faster baby so that's it I have
been mark Barnard in Kevin
I'm sure has either or will do his
review shortly and hopefully we will get
to be back together in the cantina
before too long so for this episode of
black bamboo island I'm mocking Arden
tune in next week singing that time save
that channel so knock ass calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith I'll see
you soon
you